the 2020 Democrat primary is turning
into an absolute circus and CNN is being
brutally mocked for making it even worse
CNN losing even more credibility and
turning it into a game show network by
revealing the upcoming debate lineups
like this we want to randomly draw
candidates I'm going to take them and
mix them up so that we can then draw
from the candidate box another shuffle
mix them up I'm gonna give these a good
mix I'm gonna give them a good shuffle
and place them into the debate night box
we have multiple camera views you can
watch the camera above me overhead now I
won't look into the box but you can look
into the box through the overhead camera
let's start to pick the candidates
[Laughter]
because there's so many candidates it's
broken into two nights facing off on
night one Bernie Sanders and Liz Warren
will battle to see who's the biggest
socialist and Greg and I are
particularly happy about this Marianne
Williamson will join them on stage to
spread the love and the second night
features a rematch between Biden and
Kamala Harris
we'll see if sleepy Joe will actually
fight back this time Greg I hadn't
actually seen it because I don't watch
CNN until then I think they made it less
interesting it is amazing the serious
music made it even funnier CNN is
officially the carnival news network
they already had the clowns yes now they
got the attractions they need to add a
dunk tank pie-eating contest a ring toss
where Don Lemon could toss rings on a
Chris Cuomo's head no what CNN is like I
feel like I'm being too mean or not mean
enough CNN is the network without close
friends because close friends tell you
when you're making a fool out of
yourself you know hey that's an obvious
toupee wolf or you know Chris you're not
funny
people like will come and tell you that
your fly's down or whatever or you need
mouthwash
but nobody's telling CNN that you guys
look like idiots when you do this MSNBC
should be like hey guys yeah
I got some cabbage material i News
Network shock him on the door Lisa what
do you think the strategy was here was
it just trying to grab ratings or was it
to show transparency well probably a
little bit of both but primarily for
readings and apparently this special was
literally called the draw I didn't watch
it either but I read The Washington Post
write-up about it that an eight-person
panel analyzing like every move
throughout the entire hour you had
multiple people pulling the cards and
figuring out which candidate would be on
what night so absolutely ridiculous but
on the substance what I'm interested in
looking at for the debate is how badly
diminished Biden and Bernie are
byproduct of who they're on the stage
with because remember last time Harris
did some khamel Harris did some major
damage to Joe Biden and then also filled
Bernie on the stage with Elizabeth
Warren someone who basically has the
exact same policy positions but who's
younger and more interesting I mean you
could see how that could hurt him
significantly there was a racial angle
to this whole mess and one of the CNN
analysts actually commented on it let's
watch it and Juan can respond well I
want it's also worth noting in this the
most diverse field the Democratic Party
has ever had all the first night are
white candidates and the racial
diversity is entirely in the second
night which just changes the dynamic
especially because obviously race has
been a front and center issue in America
this week it has been in this campaign
it is an issue that is sort of coursing
through this Democratic primary what do
you think about that what that means
CNN's racist then if they had they
called the D call their network racist
rules well I tell you guys see race and
everything
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know all the silliness that CNN did
that you guys rightly have mocked them
for it was a transparent operation you
could see what was going on there was no
bias implicit what kind of criticism or
critique is that and it was oh never I
don't know to me that was obvious you
know that the real news here is as Lisa
was saying you're gonna have Kamala
Harris once again up against Joe Biden
so it's gonna be the redo in Detroit
right and you want to know what's gonna
happen he said he wasn't prepared last
time let's see if he's prepared this
time but he's also gonna have Cory
Booker on that stage and if you really
look at it Booker's been far more
critical of Biden for saying not about
busing but for saying he can cross the
partisan line do business and proof I
did business with segregationist in the
past that opened a big door guess what
Cory Booker did not benefit when Kamala
Harris went up in the post so does he
see this now as his opportunity it's
gonna be like a pincer movement around
Joe Biden by the way some polls came out
today and again Biden is up I think
binds up plus 9 on everybody
but Marion's coming on strong I'm glad
you brought the polls that just came out
on because Donald Trump 48 percent
approval rating in the NBC News poll
what do you think about this spectacle
all right so I did in my head winners
and losers and really the only winner
that I saw was was Kamala Harris because
CNN is obviously a total loser by that
whole debacle and as you said they're
being rightly mocked Bernie at Bernie
and Elizabeth Warren basically because
of that draw lost the opportunity to
challenge by the norm stage so for them
they're obviously disappointed and then
Biden I put him in the loser category
because he's going against Kamala again
and also Booker right so he's going to
be subjected to likely a lot of attacks
yes based on his racial record whatever
I think that for him it would not
behoove but a synonym for him to defend
his record by really not going there
because he's it's gonna be death by a
thousand cuts so what he should do is
say look I'm not here to litigate the
past I'm on this stage to talk about now
you know starting with a man in the Oval
Office let's move
forward that's a better strategy and
then for him versus Kamla it's either
raiders versus Steelers early 70s or is
it 1976 where the Raiders came back and
actually beat them all right way so it's
analogy letmego same as not even here
let me let me just go to the the first
night because the first night's really
interesting to me I know she she's in
front one she's jumped in front of Corey
Kirsten and somebody else in New
Hampshire I'm telling you she's the
Trump
she's the Trump walk up we should put a
bet on it right now you believe that
she's gonna be President the United
States he's the wild-card I'm counting
on her getting the nomination it's
because you're voting for I was wrong on
Trump for what a year and a half so I'm
interested in Sanders versus Warren do
you think they're gonna clash because
they're interesting question because I
think is a little bit of a nice set of
rerun Warren has lots of ideas and new
ideas but it's the same music right
right and the question is is there more
benefit for them and going after each
other or teaming up and saying that Joe
Biden he's the problem he's the old
stuff and we're the new or focus on
Trump the whole time right and then the
other Lane here is Clovis Shar Bennett
of there's a lane there twelve items are
Leslie this Buddha Jake prove he belongs
yeah well these raise a lot of money so
a lot of other people think that Gregg
going back to CNN right okay forget the
candidates I feel like they have an
identity crisis right they a serious
news network are they the network on New
Year's and everybody gets drunk and then
they have these little things like they
look like Vegas who are it's an
interesting thing that's happened to
them because they refuse to label
whether they're news or commentary Fox
we do it we know everybody knows that
we're we've got opinions and we're not
you know we're not we're not reporters
you know he at least we're spouting off
opinions you know when you turn on CNN
you have no idea what you're gonna get
you'll have a guy who reports something
and then an opinion in this
breath and then get it wrong or maybe
gets it right but you can't tell it's
kind of dishonest and I think they are
it's a they are in an identity crisis
because he used they used to be
something and Don Lemon who's thrown
back drink after drink on New Year's and
calling Trump you know what and now he's
the debate moderator
sumon don't match don't slander him for
drinking I'm sorry
MSNBC used Rachel Maddow and their
debates and then you've got or the NBC
debate and then now you've got Don Lemon
who is essentially an opinion host as
you just pointed out being used in CNN
and we can you imagine if Fox did
something similar we did I just think we
should be careful on this one